[Music]
nintendo won't divulge any more details
about the switch until next week but
today we've learned about what kind of
accessories we can expect for the
upcoming system I'm Matt and this is
your Nintendo switch gamespot news
updates consumer electronics companies
snakebite has revealed its line of
nintendo switch accessories which
includes a headset and what the company
calls a starter kit the headset features
40 millimeter drivers that according to
snakebite provide crisp clear gaming
audio the kit on the other hand comes
with earbuds game cases a cleaning cloth
screen protector and carrying bag for
the handheld system snakebite also
announced new accessories for Nintendo's
retro mini console the NES classic those
include a power adapter and a nine point
eight foot extension cable for the
controller no pricing has been revealed
for anything switch related but we'll
learn more it in 10 days big reveal
event next week that kicks off at 8 p.m.
pacific on january 12 for all the news
from that and around the world of video
games stay tuned to gamespot